rise and shine it's an expresso time
what's up believe nation its Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message fix your life first over
- you go Roku pal - what did you do to
be who you are right now if you are on
an airline and then on the fly the cabin
crew will come announce that if there be
a lack of oxygen supply in the cabin
mosques will come from the panel above
your head and secure them normally and
breathe normally and make sure your mask
is in place before you assist and help
others exact so you truly cannot help
others unless you owe yourself in place
and when we talk about putting your life
in place like my personal life in place
I feel there is a great need to give
that priority to fix your life so yes
there were challenges moving from being
a HP engineer to a lifestyle engineer
moving from being a pampered son to a
monk moving from living in comfort to
living in meager facilities in the
ashram in the monastery there were
challenges but these were all external
challenges the internal challenges were
am I missing out you out there if I put
my fire out they would probably be
really elevated to a very high position
in the industry so initially when I just
came in the challenge was am I missing
out and that challenge was taken care of
by seeing the kind kind of lives that
were being impacted by what I was doing
the satisfaction I felt in trying to
bring a difference and making that
impact was able to kind of deal with the
challenge of failing that I miss out on
something I don't think I must start on
anything at any point because seeing
people's life change is what very
imparting that great joy your purpose
comes from your pain and your ability to
help others is a direct result of the
pain and suffering that you have been
through humans are good 90
nine point nine percent of humans are
good and we are built to serve we want
to help others and the path to help
others is through the pain and suffering
that you have been through so that
others don't have to experience the same
things that you went through yourself
most people are stuck most people don't
know how to bring more meaning into
their life most people don't know what
their purpose is most people don't know
what they're designed to do and at the
same time they're trying to avoid the
past so trying to forget the mistakes
that have happened they're trying to run
away from the pain that has happened to
them where the real answer is combining
those two things together your purpose
comes from your pain all of that
suffering that you went through all the
negative experiences that you are
currently running away from that is your
purpose not living there and we're
experiencing it over and over and over
again but using that as leverage using
that as wisdom using that as information
to help other people who are currently
suffering with those same ailments let
me give you a quick example I had a guy
come to my workshop here in Toronto
where I train people how to be thought
leaders and make money from their ideas
and he was telling me his story about
abuse and depression and suicide and
just really nasty stuff that happened to
him in his family and his upbringing and
for me I care a lot about suicide I care
a lot about depression but I can't
really speak to it much because I've
never gone through it because I never
even came close to thinking about
killing myself because I've never yes
I've had bad moments but I've never felt
like I'm in such a negative funk I'm in
such a depressed state that never really
happened to me
I can't authentically say that I had
depression who wanted to kill myself and
so why would you listen to me on those
things the most that I could say is I
think it's really bad and if you are
suicidal please go get help but I don't
have the exact answer to give you
because I haven't been through it but
this guy who came to my workshop he did
he can help people because he got
through it
he suffered through it and he figured
out a path on how it saved his life and
by sharing that by embracing that it
allows him to potentially save the lives
of tens or hundreds or thousands or
hundreds of thousands of people my
purpose is helping entrepreneurs because
I struggled so much being an
entrepreneur myself because I was making
it $300 a month because I was too
embarrassed to tell my friends that I
was sucking and making no money because
I was eating the same being lunch
every single day because I struggled so
much because I felt so little confidence
in myself because I didn't believe in
myself enough now I want to help other
people because I understand that
struggle because I have been through it
myself now my purpose is to help other
people not suffer the same pain that I
did so your ability to help people is a
direct result of the pain and suffering
and struggle that you have been through
but you recognizing this big challenge
in your life and overcoming it you can
then teach people and help people how
they can overcome it in their life as
well and if you're still struggling with
something right now if we haven't
figured it out if you're still in the
hole and you are suffering try to change
your mindset that this is the best try
to change your mindset from a place up
this sucks I'm never gonna get out of
here my life is over too when I figure
this out I will be a force for good for
the world
when I figure this out when I pass
through this phase in my life and I
climb out of this hole I'm gonna serve
so many people so that they never feel
this pain that I am feeling right now
your purpose comes from your pain now
I've got a really special bonus clip for
you but before that question of the day
I want to know what is your purpose let
me know put it down in the comments
below
we live in a world where we almost lose
control of all of our time every day we
have arrows that I call them arrows that
come at us hey Jesse can you spend 15
minutes with this guy he wants to pick
you're bringing on coconut water and hey
can you pay this guy this guy wants to
borrow $50 and this email needs to be
vertical like constantly dodging all
this stuff and we feel obligated and say
yes because we don't want to feel you
know let anyone down and we lose control
of our time how could you be productive
have a vibrant life be successful if
someone else controls all your time or
you filled with clutter so it did a very
simple thing
we can all do it I drew a pie chart okay
I said there's 24 hours in the day I
sleep seven of them
that leaves 17 hours in the day I take
three of them for me and those three
hours could do anything that I want I
could be I'm going for a run a steam I'm
doing nothing I'm doing my emails I'm
reading but I don't want to resent my
wife I don't want to resent my boss I
don't resent my partner for taking away
the things in my life that I love to do
by controlling my time three hours for
me the average American works a 40-hour
workweek that's eight hours a day seven
four sleep three for yourself eight for
work guess what you got six hours left
in the day all the clutter is gone now
of course you have to commute you have
dinner you have family you have meals
the point is you can be incredibly
productive incredibly creative
incredibly free when you take control of
your time when you figure out how you
want to attack your time over the course
of a week so it's not selfish to put
yourself first so it's self full its
self full self old to be first to be as
good as possible to you to take care of
you to keep you whole and healthy that
doesn't mean that you disregard
everything and everyone but you want to
come with your cup full you know my cup
runneth over what comes out of the cup
is for y'all what's in the cup is mine
but I gotta keep my
don't we do that don't we take on other
people's stuff and make it about someone
we don't know that we matter when you
don't know you matter you will make
somebody else's crazy about you you got
your own stuff to handle you don't have
to take on anybody else's people violate
you when you don't have clear boundaries
because you don't tell them how to
behave in your life and they run amok
they run amok because you don't have
clear boundaries raise your standard
Apple at the core its core values is
that we believe that people with passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's up to me if you guys want to
learn more about guru Gopal das I highly
recommend the top ten rules video that I
did on him continue to believe I hope
you enjoy today's shot a vinspresso and
I'll see you on the next video do
something in the game of life you're
playing a cricket match